I compliment you on the hair the hair is
iconic thank you no seriously I write
back at you dude I'm loving the whole
wave of caramel how long did it take you
to grow this hair um well I've always
had longer hair like you know ever since
high school I had like a an afro is what
they call it yeah I I rolled with an
afro in my high school years because I
couldn't really grow it long because I
needed to cut it for like school photos
because you know if you look like a
burnout in your school photos
grandparents are gonna come sniffing
around you yeah okay so the school photo
would come up you would like get a buzz
cut or something trim it up real tight
on the sides a little curl on the top
and then you know you're in the clear
because if you're if you're looking like
you know a grunge rocker and you're in
your photo you're gonna get that call
from Aunt Tilly and she's gonna be like
search his underwear drawer because he's
he's in the seitan or something jazz
cigarettes they used to call those jazz
cigarette I had an uncle once who said
tell me that guy's not smoking those
jazz cigarettes this was like in 1985
now how did you get started in comedy
I'm curious um well it wasn't so much
comedy where I got started my first gig
on on the television was public access
in my hometown Concord California um we
had a hardcore backyard backyard
wrestling show you you and your friends
did backyard wrestling we did seven of
seven of my real tight dude friends we
would we would go to my my my buddy Kyle
who's Carl our our our drug dealer on
the show we would uh the guy who let's
clarify the guy who plays your drug
dealer yes
that guy yeah we would go into his
backyard set up like a big entrance and
we weren't really trying to hit each
other this wasn't like real backyard
wrestling it was like foil molded into
weapons and we just kind of love tap
each other hey you guys would seriously
do this yes it was honor I signed an
autograph when I worked at the movie
theater a kid came up he's like oh
that's rockabilly Rex because he had
seen you do backyard wrestling on public
access television is right that's
fantastic yeah gave me the taste like
this is real show business now of course
you didn't you never got hurt doing this
right this is this was all pretty safe
no it was all fake blood it's a lot of
like um gently resting your friends on
mattresses and being like are you okay
dude okay I'm a drop take you now it's
bad when you can hear that yeah yeah I
think if you look the tapes you can
pretty much hear a lot of a lot of
loving check-in but am I correct you you
were injured not long ago but I don't
know was that to the wrestling uh no
that was just from real life beings
being just being aa drunken and dumb and
and stupid like I am what it would it
what did you do maybe with this can be a
cautionary tale for all the youngsters
watch sure it was it was just a minor
injury I I broke my back did you really
break your back yeah dude I did I I uh
well I I just I fell off a roof threw a
beer pong table
did you fall off the roof was that an
accident that you fell well that's what
that's the story we're sticking to but
you know I might have I might have been
influenced by drugs and alcohol okay
well be that as it may you were on a
roof I was you ended up on a beer pong
table I did I assumed that some kind of
substance was involved sure we weren't
up there installing cable no well I was
hoping maybe I could do like a cool NBA
Jam like slam dunk or something but it
just and you broke your back I did I
broke my back I had to go into surgery
for like seven hours they took a rib out
it but I'm good baby full recovery baby
over how we do it yeah
we actually as happens you happen to
someone was shooting this filming this
video is that right yeah it was a big
party there were a lot of people there
in cell phones they've just have changed
everything well let's take a look
usually I'm saying let's take a look at
this oscar-nominated clip but instead
let's look at Blake falling drunk off a
roof onto a beer pong table and breaking
it back
yeah
that was not a clip from workaholics
surprising